він двічі підкорив Говерлу прожив три
місяці віндонезії пірнав на дно океану й
катався на екстремальних атракціонах і
все це з пересадженим серцем складно
повірити але ще 7 років тому Максим
греков був За крок до смерті лише
трансплантація подарувала йому друге
життя почитав хто як живе після
пересадки попрощався із баскетболом і
спортом із горами з дайвінгом з усім за
три роки сумарно після пересадки Я встиг
зробити все це для сам себе здивувався з
цього приводу насправді
року в Україні потребують трансплантації
близько 5 тисяч людей але більше як
половина з них помирає так і не
дочекавшись операції а змінити цю
статистику можна Всього одна заява на
заповнення якої йде до 10 хвилин у
майбутньому здатна врятувати близько
5-ти життів йдеться про згоду на
посмертне донорство її приміром вже
підписала українська ведуча і громадська
активістка Ярослава Кравченко кілька
років тому актори Андрій Панас
раптово загинув і після своєї смерті
після його смерті дружина дала дозвіл на
трансплантацію і він врятував фактично
своїми органами трьох чи чотирьох людей
яким е-е їх пересадили і мене тоді так
ця історія зачепила І я подумала треба
дізнатися треба дізнатися звичайно
якийсь час йшов а сьогодні коли ти
розумієш що
смерть більше вірогідна особливо якщо Ти
залишаєшся весь час в Україні то
хотілося б щоб вона
була якщо що не марною і могла допомогти
про своє рішення Ярослава написала у
соцмережах набагатотисячну аудиторію
деяких підписників приклад ведучої
надихнув А ось її маму спочатку налякав
Моя мама дуже злякалась тому що вона
спочатку побачила Stories що я
де вона побачила слово тільки
трансплантація я сиджу в Амосова в мене
розривається телефон я все що за
трансплантацію Каже мама потім розкажу
Зачекай мені п'ять людей відписалося з
моїх підписників що вони теж пішли і теж
надали згоду Мені здається що це дуже
крутий результат і це справді так Для
прикладу у центрі трансплантації на базі
лікарні Феофанія за три роки було
зареєстровано лише три пожиттєві згоди
дві з них ведмедиків у масштабах
багатомільйонного Києва це по суті Ніщо
ми покриваємо може 5-7% від потреби це
кількість донорів відношення до
кількості реципієнтів які знаходяться
лисках очікування нема
донорів нема донорських скажемо так
органів які б дозволили нам виконати
необхідну кількість трансплантацій
міфів і упереджень щодо донорства
особливо посмертного одяг такі міфи що
ти зараз підпишеш і тебе все там
підборотні в темному кутку вб'ють і
розберуть на органи але тоді це має бути
фантастично так уявити банда
кваліфікованих хірургів трансплантологів
які чатують на тебе в якійсь підвородній
у реальному житті нелегальна пересадка
це по суті Смертельний вирок і ось чому
окрім співпадіння за групою або
сумісністю за групою треба ще Провести
ряд імунологічних тестів які покажуть
нам що у разі пересадки органа організм
реципієнта невідторний цей орган миттєво
достатньо складної дороговартісні процес
який наразі в Україні можна зробити там
грубо кажучи в 2-3 клініках у всій
Україні загалом необхідні спеціалі і це
зроблять не так багато спеціалістів які
можуть цим займатися і можуть це зробити
якісно тому потрібні е-е надзвичайно
стерильні умови в яких це буде зроблено
тому що якщо під час трансплантації
відбувається інфікування е-е
реципієнт або органа оцього на етапах
транспортування або десь то це майже
100% призведе до смерті реципієнта
навіть якщо людина дає згоду на
посмертне донорство за життя це не
означає що її органи комусь і колись
пересадять має співпасти чимало чинників
насамперед важливі обставини смерті
переважно донорами стають після
інсультів тоді мозок людини помирає але
медикам ще якийсь час вдається штучно
підтримувати життєдіяльність органів
лікарі зробили все що могли для того щоб
врятувати життя і ось Після цього
ми починаємо лише після цього думати чи
може ця людина бути донором спілкуватись
з родичами
дивитись в електронній інформаційній
системі чи давала ця людина життя за
життя згоду на посмертну до націю
люди певно не вірять в те що таке
відбулося Да що їх людина що їх родич
там або рідна людина померла
вони
може вважають що
кваліфікація лікарів або якість медичної
допомоги яка надавалась вона недостатня
і можна зробити ще щось і Людина яка не
має відношення до медицини може вважати
що родичі ще живий в нього ж працюють
там серце легені працюють там нирки
працюють то він живий Як це так у
2022-му кількість трансплантацій в
Україні зросла на 20%. але це ніяк не
пов'язано з війною за законом військові
та цивільні чия смерть настала внаслідок
бойових дій донорами ставати не можуть
ні військовий ні цивільний ми
розглядаються тобто
люди стають донорами за тих самих
обставин якби війни не було колеги з-за
кордону
е-е часто мене питали зараз вже
перестали скажіть чому у вас зараз може
різко збільшити кількість донації
анатомічних матеріалів але з огляду на
ось цю етичну складову е-е і на ті речі
які
я думаю що будь-якому фахівцю не
повністю закордоном не повністю
зрозумілі тому що вони не проходять
через це вони це не переживають в
Україні було прийнято рішення не
змінювати
нормативні документи особисті дані
українців які дали згоду на посмертне
донорство надійно захищені переконують у
центрі трансплант координації до моменту
настання смерті інформація з єдиної
електронної системи засекречена для всіх
електронна система охорони здоров'я і
хелс про згоду за життя теж нічого не
знаю
технічно фізично тобто жоден лікар інших
галузей і навіть трансплантологія не
можуть
з'ясувати Петренко чи Сидоренко давав
згоду чи надавав це
до розвінчування міфу про те що якщо я
дам згоду то за мною почнеться полювання
і десь на зупинці мене
для того щоб я став донором такого бути
не може чим більше українці
позбуватимуться своїх упереджень
тимчастіше ставатимуться історії
порятунку восени 22-го року
був випадок коли мама померлого
самостійно звернулась от до лікарів А
про те що вона хотіла щоб її син
врятував інші життя
З дотриманням всіх етичних складових
відбулось вилучення цих анатомічних
матеріалів які а потім роз'їхались по
різних лікарнях і було врятовано дві
дитини наприклад двоє дорослих якби не
донор серце не було б врятовано Максима
Грекова я Скажімо так враховуючи Мій
стан навряд чи дотягнув би до
мовно до двох років
з підготовки до операції з видалення
апендициту в Максима виявили серйозні
відхилення в роботі серця Скажімо так до
цього моменту я у
у лікарні був можу у зубного пару разів
за 32 роки тобто в мене жодних проблем
не було зі здоров'ям тобто я дуже
дивувався я навіть не знав що таке
Аспірин ну реально Не знав і що він
потрібен
назву діагнозує пару днів вивчав
дилатаційна кардіоміопатія ну Ані У мого
батька не було проблем серця Ані У Мого
діда Тобто Це просто може статися з
будь-ким будь коли і ніхто насправді від
цього не застрахований на жаль
після успішної пересадки серця у 2016-му
Максим почав друге життя новий насичене
я роблю більше ніж робив до цього тому
що до цього ти думаєш що в тебе завжди є
завтра ти післязавтра а зараз зрозумієш
що ні ну олімпійські рекорд Я вже не
поставлю точно тому що серце працює ну
воно так суб'єктивно дає відсотків 70
мабуть і того що давали мені моє перше
Але для того щоб грати на вулиці в
баскетбол Мені достатньо пересаджене
серце допомогти ЗСУ я зняти з
військового обліку через це я можу
спокійно виїжджати це заїжджати в
Україну власне тому
Хлопці хто Хто що міг там послідувалися
є знайомі в Данії вони взяли тачку І
власне я зганяв там за однією машиною
потім я ще з Болгарію одну машину до
цього також на саме тому що я просто
можу це зробити
так що є якісь плюси в інвалідності саме
чи єсь рішення про посмертне донорство
врятувало Максиму життя Тож сьогодні він
розповідає свою історію аби надихнути
українців не боятися давати пожиттєву
згоду на посмертне донорство
[музика]